although individual dark matter
particles have very little influence
taken as a whole they've had enormous
employees now what we know is that most
of the dark matter surrounds galaxies
and enormous roughly spherical halos
however there's maybe a possibility and
this is something that I researched with
my collaborators that there was also a
small fraction of the dark matter that
has interactions and that seems kind of
who cares it's only 5% but if that's
true there's a possibility that this
dark matter radiates and forms a disc
very much like the Milky Way - so if you
think about it in our galaxy we have
this enormous Dark Matter halo but then
we have a disc of the Milky Way and I
corresponds to matter that radiated and
collapse to form the Milky Way disc
maybe dark matter
again not most of it maybe some of it
does the same in which case there would
be a thin disc of dark matter embedded
in the plane in the Milky Way now what
does this have to do with extinctions
well here's some interesting possibility
so the solar system goes around the
galaxies circles around basically every
2 into 40 million years but as it does
so it bumps up and down a little bit
which means that maybe if there's the
right amount of dark matter every 30 or
35 million years the solar system will
encounter an enhanced gravitational
force due to this very dense dark disk
in the middle of the Milky Way if that's
the case it could have some interesting
consequences because in addition to the
stuff we know about our solar system the
planets and even the asteroids really
very far out maybe 50,000 times further
away than the earth is from the Sun
there's something called the Oort cloud
that's a source of long period comets so
you have these very weakly bound comets
at the edge of our solar system but then
if they encounter the gravitational
force of a dark disc they could get
dislodge when would this happen well
it's gonna happen roughly every 30 35
million years when we pass through
we passed through the last time maybe
two million years ago so it could be
that one of those passages was quite
triggered a comment I came to earth and
caused all the devastation
I killed the dinosaurs and 2/3 of the
species on the planet